trees are big three monsters are strange
and also big and so here in this video
we will showcase 15 of the biggest of
these type of movie monsters we will
take the awesome ones from the recent
movies and shows we will start with
relatively human sized ones and make our
way up to the absolutely gigantic
monsters so subscribe if you haven't
already and now let's get down to
business
at number 15 we have the kinoshi mobe
from the show grim we get the tree
monster bearing the name kinoshimobi
which was terrifying to look at this
creature has a humanoid figure and was
around seven feet tall kinoshimobis are
colossal plant-based humanoids with
chlorophyll as blood
when they attack they ensnare their
victims in vines before stabbing them
they have the ability to shoot vines
from both their hands and their feet
they are quite strong despite their slow
movement they can easily live a fully
grown human
14
groot from the mcu we get groot more
specifically from the movie guardians of
the galaxy vol 1. groot is a floral
colossus and originally the accomplice
of rocket raccoon floral colossus are
humanoid in form with thick robot's body
structure that makes them almost
invulnerable to physical harm they have
a highly accelerated healing factor able
to grow limbs regrow them and even their
entire bodies from nothing more than a
twig growth the adult version was around
eight feet tall and was an integral part
of the guardians of the galaxy
number 13 the burj the birch is a 2017
short horror film scene in crypt tv and
here we see a female tree master of the
same name the birch is an 8 foot tall
humanoid creature her body is
constructed of birch wood as her name
suggests her head's upper half rises
into a crown of huge branches wrapped
around in vines that resemble horns she
doesn't have legs but but she does have
lengthy fingers composed of two eggs and
branches her face is skeleton her eyes
are deep and lifeless and her teeth are
crooked
number 12 leshi now coming from the
netflix tv series the witcher season 2
we get an ominous and cool looking
staple monster of the franchise which is
the leshi the lashi is masculine and
humanoid in shape is able to assume any
likeness and can change in size and
height the first form we see is the
infected witcher that was turned into
one that kind of looked like a tree
human hybrid and then later the main
leshi was seen in the middle of the
forest as a vaguely humanoid tree
that can attack with its roots it was
somewhere between 12 to 15 feet tall but
was killed by a mere pot
number 11 spriggans coming in from the
disney movie maleficent we get the three
warriors of the moors and they are
called the spriggans spriggans are an
army of humanoid trees that inhabit the
most and when king henry's army attempt
to take over the moors maleficent showed
up and called the three warriors and the
forest dragon to defeat the human
kingdom's army these creatures were also
seen later in the movie acting as
sentries and guards over the north they
were large beings more than 15 to 20
feet tall
number 10 the ends a lot of the rings
also has a couple of entries in this
list and the first one which is smaller
of the two are ends ants are tree-like
creatures who over millennia became more
and more like the trees they heard it
they varied in height size coloring and
number of fingers and toes although an
individual end usually resembles the
tree they guard it trivia the leader was
around 15 to 20 feet tall although some
ends are bigger than trivia standing at
around 30 feet in height
number 9 the spur mantis this monster
versus flora fauna hybrid of the 2017
movie skull island also makes it to this
list and it holds a ninth spot both the
body and limbs of the spermantas
resemble fallen trees in fact bark is a
part of the species epidermis beneath
this deceptive layer lies a parasitic
slug with powerful jaws
with this tree-like body the spermatus
can blend in with the surrounding forest
this creature varies in size depending
on individuals with the largest being
around 40 feet long
number eight the whomping willow from
harry potter and the prisoner of azkaban
we get this creepy tree that guards an
entrance a secret one and it is named
the whomping willow whopping willows
would attack anyone and anything that
came within a range of its branches it
is suggested it was planned with limbs
functioning as arms and any damage to
them must be treated in much the same
way the most famous whomping willow was
the one planet in the grounds of
hogwarts school of witchcraft and
wizardry this one cannot move from its
side but can grow upwards to around 25
to 30 feet in height
number 7 the angry molesting tree
terrifying and perverted and around 20
to 30 feet in height we get an entry
from evil dead and the cabin in the
woods it is depicted as a large leafless
and slow moving tree judging by its name
it can be assumed that the angry
molesting tree harasses or kills its
victim in an extreme nature such as
sexual assault the roots and branches of
the tree protrude from the sides and the
rear of it which help it move around and
ensnare its victims
number six the poltergeist tree another
horror movie entry we see a tree that
haunts a kid and his family in the form
of a poltergeist tree the tree is a
minor antagonist in the 1982 film
poltergeist and its 2015 remake of the
same name it is a tree planted outside a
family house that becomes possessed by
either the beast or one of the many
ghosts haunting the grounds in a 2015
remake the tree appears as a willow with
green leaves and long drooping branches
attached to a thick trunk and it was
around 30 feet tall
number five a monster from monster calls
from the movie a monster calls we get
liam neeson transform into a gigantic
tree monster and this one isn't actually
named and was just called the monster so
this monster is a giant humanoid tree
creature that walks upright like a human
and is over three stories tall which
puts him between 40 to 50 feet in height
the monster befriends a kid and tells
him three stories and in return the kid
must tell him one
number four the hunts now the second
entry from the law of the rings to two
towers we get a less sentient yet larger
form of the ends and these are the
hurons of fan gone forest huanz were a
living race of ancient slow-moving trees
whom the ends cared for and tended to in
the second and third ages the hunts
mostly stood as dark trees in a deeper
forest null and unmoving yet watchful
when aroused in wrath they move swiftly
as if wrapped in shadows falling on foes
with deadly and merciless strength they
are the height of different trees some
are over 150 feet tall
number three the forest dragon the
second entry from the movie maleficent
we see a monster that was seen only in
the beginning scenes of the movie in the
form of a woody slash rude serpentine
monster called the forest dragon the
forest dragon is a creature responsible
for defending the moors and during the
attempt of king henry's armies to take
over the moors maleficent called on the
force dragon and the tree warriors to
war and it was easily more than 200 feet
long
number two am hoolig the second largest
was briefly seen in the monitor screens
of godzilla king of the monsters and
then later in the comics called godzilla
dominion of the monster verse itself and
this one is none other than titanos i'm
hulu this titan was more than 350 feet
tall and was sort of a demonic tree
hybrid that can stretch its limbs to
unimaginable lengths and was seen
battling the behemoth and winds but was
eventually knocked down by godzilla
himself in kotm we only see him as a
name on the screen locked up in a
containment in monarch outpost 66
and number one godzilla earth and yes of
course the g-man must appear on a master
list and here in this one he is the
biggest godzilla earth is a tree slash
reptile hybrid kaiju and it is
determined that it was the apex of
evolution on any planet that crosses a
certain threshold in life-form
development godzilla earth is over 300
meters or more than 1 000 feet in height
he was seen in the anime movie trilogy
of godzilla planet of the monsters he
differs from the other incarnation as he
is quite a complex creature with
electromagnetic biology coupled with
reptilian and plant physiology
so i hope you have enjoyed watching this
video anyway with that we come to the
end of it so do hit that like button for
support and subscribe as well to be a
part of the mind cue family but most of
all smash that bell icon for regular
updates on new videos right here on this
channel
till next one take care fam